the god idea is the opposite idea of of
evolution in that it what it needs so
much as an explanation is way out of
proportion to what it actually explains
it does the very opposite of of
evolution um so stev just said that idea
of people getting their head around that
something so complicated could be
explained by something so
simple given the sort of
earlier culture and the life that people
had which was so theologically focused
that the idea
of the very that it's such a reversal of
what was taken for granted that it is a
Hu it's a huge conceptual leap for
anybody to make isn't it massive and one
of the things I was talking about how
people seized on the idea and in some
ways misunderstood it and you might even
think wilfully did one thing that
happened I maybe we'll bring in Steven
Pinker on this is the idea that somehow
you know genes were Destiny and this is
what D decided people even individually
it was all encoded that's been an era a
sort of misconception in you know
popular thinking for decades do what
role did your book play in either
confounding that or actually because of
that potential to misunderstand in
people thinking ah so that person's like
that because of their gen yes in so far
as it played a role was it was massively
misunderstood I mean um the question of
Destiny is a deep philosophical question
which down then it's contributed a lot
to but it doesn't become a different
problem if you suddenly bring genes in
so we can ignore the idea of genetic
determinism could I add one more thing
to the mystery of why it to took so long
um Ernst Meyer the great centenarian um
founding father of modern um
evolutionary genetics um suggested that
it was because of platonic um
essentialism um if you if you if you're
a geometer like like Plato then then you
see a triangle um as a or some or a
sphere as an ideal form and he regarded
real triangles and real spheres as kind
of imperfect approximations to this
ideal Myers's theory is that people were
used to that idea applied to living
things so you had an ideal rabbit an
ideal
rhinoceros and real rabbits and real
rhinoceroses were
approximations to this ideal form and if
you think of if you think of rabbits and
rhinoceroses and kangaroos as having
ideal forms you're automatically
resistant to the idea that they could
change into something else so that's
me's explanation for why it took so long
that so there was actually a barrier in
the way we saw the Dead Hand of Plato
yes we can always blame Plato for
everything the um because can I just add
on on Plato in that case um wonderful
story that there was an ancient history
Dawn in in new College who you mean he
was a very old Dawn or he was a Don in
history he he did end up rather old but
but but um and his life's work this is
an exaggeration was to decide whether
Plato or Paul was the greatest of
all
time well you've elegantly taken us to
because I to our next subject really
which is about religion um I should
mention that we going to I'm
deliberately going to leave a lot of
time for your own questions to this
panel in particular I'm sure for Richard
Dawkins so I'm going to just push on uh
and get on to this you know other huge
area which in which you've written so
prominently and it is the book which is
also 10 years old this year The God
Delusion um let's just why don't you
kick us off Daren Darren about this the
the how important uh you know Richard
Dawkins he was hailed as one of sort of
a group of So-Cal new atheists uh and in
your own uh work in this tour that
you're doing now you describe it as
secular Faith healing that's part of it
why don't you tell us what that is what
that idea is about and what sort of debt
it owes to what Richard dorin and others
have been writing in this
area yes well I I grew up a a Christian
and and went to various quite happy
clappy churches as well as quite quiet
Anglican ones and uh sort of grew out of
it because I didn't really have a
Christian uh family or friends
particularly um so I sort of drifted out
of it at University after having become
a hypnotist and a magician and things
that sort of made me think more
skeptically it was only reading The God
Delusion that kind of I think as for a
lot of people finally gave it a sort of
a language and uh in the way that you
tend to find things inspiring that
articulate something you already kind of
feel but haven't really found the
language for um so now how many years on
20 15 years on no 10 15 years on since
then since reading it Pard 10 10
goodness yeah I um yeah I'm doing a
secular Faith healing show at the moment
which I'm touring with and it's uh it's
there was definitely a guilty moment I
think a couple of years after I'd come
out of a belief when somebody actually
said well do you believe in God then and
I sort of said no and it was the first
time I'd actually said that had a little
little burst of guilty adrenaline and
that was it it just disappeared that was
gone um but uh but yes it's I'm now in
this interesting situation where I'm um
taking an
audience largely like you I mean
certainly not an Evangelical audience
probably the very polar opposite of an
of an Evangelical audience and doing
Faith healing on them every night um
healing them uh and I've got them you
know falling over in the aisles and all
the rest of it and something I thought
would never would never happen it's been
a very interesting project I thought I'd
start off understanding the mechanics of
how it would work and how I could sort
of get it to work with a with a secular
and very skeptical audience I thought
I'd maybe achieve a bit of sort of pain
relief and that you create enough
adrenaline and people will not feel pain
I didn't expect to get quite the extent
of response that it's that it's had so
it's been a very and it's part of your
purpose in doing it to expose as fake
somehow healing that is in the name of
Faith your showing it it doesn't yeah
yeah well the part of the problem with
any sort of debunking is that you're
you're sort of just saying um you know
normally no this thing isn't this isn't
true and you're trying to supply facts
to the contrary or to the contrary of
the demonstrations that you're trying to
discredit um which isn't really a very
interesting or entertaining message
compared to what the the charlatans
themselves are doing which obviously is
much more sort of engaging so what I've
always tried to do is replicate um so
you didn't want the religious devil to
have all the good shoes oh absolutely
yeah but if you just stand there and
explain how a psychic works for example
and somebody will listen to that
probably and go okay well that's how
psychic but not how the psychic does it
that I saw because she made me feel this
so therefore it must be something else
to so what happens apart from them
falling down in the aisles I mean what
do you have them well they they properly
healed maybe get up under their
Wheelchairs and maybe not for very long
but they are I mean I've I've had
there's a small percentage of people I
mean I don't know what the percentage is
but I'm guessing a very small percentage
of people that do say just so you know
it's 3 months later and the authoriz is
is still gone um I'd imagine 99% of
people it's an entirely temporary thing
that happens there and I'm very open
about this and it is done in a i i play
the role of the faith healer but I
absolutely bookend it with um uh you
know very open about what's what's going
on um your point your point your point
as suppose is to show that So-Cal real
Faith healers are actually what fakes
and that there's nothing religious about
it yeah or certainly I mean the most I
can show of course is that here is
something that can be perfectly well
reproduced it doesn't therefore
logically extend to therefore all of
that must be fake but certainly what I
find myself doing is taking the bits
that can be reproduced and going well
look this can certainly be done without
recourse to a an extraordinary
explanation